Stanley Carnot author of the new book in
our image America's Empire in the
Philippines when did you first think you
wanted to be a writer well it goes back
you know early stories it goes back to
your jelly pad when you're eight years
old and you print your own newspaper for
your friends and school and I guess it
was when I started out in high school
love getting on school newspaper being
an editor of my college newspaper it's
something I always wanted to do and use
the word writer I consider myself to be
journalists if there's perhaps a
conflict in those terms but I've really
spent all my life
professional and non-professional in the
field of journalism what's the
difference between being a journalist
and a writer well let's put it this way
journalists are writers but not all
writers or journalists and I I use the
distinction because the word journalism
contains the French word ruler which is
means day and there is a time quality a
temporal quality to journalism as
opposed to literature poetry you really
are under pressure as a journalist that
same pressure exists I discovered if
you're working for a wire service or
you're working for a newspaper a daily
newspaper or you're working for a
magazine a weekly magazine or a monthly
magazine or even if you're writing books
books take a long time but still you
have a deadline you want to accomplish
it you want to finish it we're going to
frame a time framework I'm not saying
that poets don't try to finish their
poems with a certain deadline but I the
other aspect of journalism is that it's
nonfiction it may be vivid it may read
like fiction and I try in my histories
or current affairs books to to make it
vivid and to bring the journalists
instruments and tools to it in in
depicting things as if they're actually
happening under my very eyes even though
they may have happened 100 years ago
which requires a lot of research I
guarantee I don't invent it I go back
and read all newspapers or if I can
interview people who have recollections
so I try to get that kinetic live
quality into it because if I can go on
because I believe that history is made
by people it's not made by cosmic forces
it's not ordained or preordained and so
I want to tell it in terms of people and
you remember back in those early days
why you were even interested in being a
journalist in the first place well it's
hard to remember what my motives were I
guess I like to write I liked I like to
toy with words I remember when I was in
high school I used to write radio plays
this is before the days of television
which dates me I like the drama of that
and I'd like observing events and then
trying to recreate them and analyze them
if I could of course I started out as a
sports writer in high school I was a
sports editor of the paper I don't pay
much attention to sports anymore but
that was a glamorous thing to do when
you were a high school kid you went to
all the football games and the
cheerleaders got to know you and it was
a it was a nice avocation as a high
school student later in college as an
editor of the paper I mostly
concentrated on editorials would also
like to write light feature stuff you
know those days my my inspiration was
the New Yorker magazine which was funny
and lively I think it's gotten a bit
ponderous in recent years so I got
launched if you want or I launched
myself in that
and like everybody getting out of
college went out to look for a job and
the had a very kind of odd way of
finding a professional job I went over
to Paris after I graduated from college
I went over there for the summer liked
it was intrigued and captivated by it
and stayed on it fortunately in those
days we had the GI Bill I had been in
the Army during the Second World War so
I had something like three or four years
of GI Bill coming to me those were the
days when the dollar was strong and
believe it or not you could actually
live in Paris on a hundred dollars a
month I mean today you barely pays for
lunch and so I kind of hung out if you
want I mean I enrolled in school in
order to get my GI Bill did go to
classes did get the required diplomas
and so forth of which which are really
valuable in a way but by some chance I
got hired by Time magazine first as a
spear carrier and a general factotum I
spoke French by this stage and
eventually became a correspondent of
time and that was the beginning of my
professional career back in 1950 I want
to get to some more of that and some of
the work you do for the Washington Post
and others but first one I asked you
first show the audience what your book
looks like and by now they've probably
seen in the bookstores they've seen the
part of the television show that you're
doing with PBS the first question I want
to ask you and I know this book is about
the Philippines right down the bottom
author of Vietnam history that book also
was made into a television series on PBS
where did you get the idea to combine
your books with television well I felt
that that television could do a lot of
things in telling a story I mean you
can't you can't really dramatize certain
events in words
in the same way you can you could do it
on the screen I mean the old Chinese
adage about a picture being worth a
thousand words I think is is modest I
think a good picture might be worth a
whole chapter in a book and certain
events very dramatic events are just an
almost impossible to capture in words
but television has its limitations it's
very hard in a ongoing documentary to
analyze things television requires
images and visual visuals it requires
photographs or film for example if
you're trying to deal with a diplomatic
negotiation what have you got on
television what have you got to deal
with usually you can't get into the room
to listen to people bargaining so you
either have the opening shot that the
negotiators allow the television cameras
to do or you get pictures of people
getting in and out of cars
none of that very satisfactory and
there's a limited attention span I think
on the part of the viewer for an
analysis of what's going on inside that
room but you can do that in the book in
this book for example I was able to
obtain the transcript of a debate that
went on in the Reagan administration in
February 1986 over whether to what to do
about Ferdinand Marcos in those final
days in the Philippines and so I have
the the actual dialogue of that that
meeting what Secretary of State Shultz
said to the Secretary of Defense
Weinberger later in the day what
President Reagan said to both of them
and I can take the time in the book I
can take the space in the book to
describe it so the book analyzes
interprets whereas television shows and
dramatizes and I think a combination of
the two
to complement each other and I think
give you this rounder picture this
broader canvas or two canvases to work
on back to that first book he did this
you know this this joint project of the
Vietnam history whose idea was it to do
the combination in television and in the
book well the idea of the television
series was proposed to me by Laurence K
Grossman who was then the president of
public broadcasting in a rather nice
setting we were lying on the beach in
that Tucket in summer in 1977 I think it
was and he said what about doing a
television series on Vietnam and I had
spent a lot of time in Vietnam
longer than I like to recall in fact and
I long by the way well I started going
out there in the 50s so I was there from
the 50s and then even fact in fact for
the television series in the book went
back in the early 1980s so I clocked
about 25 years of in and out of Vietnam
at any rate Grossman proposed the
television series I thought it was a
very good idea and I thought it was very
farsighted of him at that particular
time this was 2 years after the fall of
Saigon to the Communists the American
public was thoroughly uninterested in
the subject and it took us seven years
to do it and by the time we did come out
I think attitudes have changed I like to
think that maybe we contributed after
coming out to changing the attitudes but
by that time the Vietnam Memorial had
gone up was going up in Washington
veterans were getting a new look and so
we were part of this whole new interest
in the Vietnam story which of course has
proliferated and expanded since then in
the course at the very beginning when
the idea of doing a television series
attracted me I also began to think that
I wanted to do a book that went with it
as a companion you can either call the
book the companion to the series of the
series of companion to the book whatever
a series started first in your mind well
the idea of the series started first
and then I did the book actually along
with the series it wasn't as if I wrote
the book and then the series was derived
from the book I'd run up and and work do
my interviews or whatever do my writing
for the series and run back and work on
the book for a while the research of one
helped the other and so I was doing them
in tandem which was quite a load to
carry I might add at any rate I am NOT a
filmmaker I'm a writer and I had done
some television documentaries before but
I did have to learn about what what it's
like to work on television although I
had marvelous people are working with me
the executive producer dick Ellison
others Lawrence lichty who was a head of
research and so I saw it very early on
as a as a combination as a package of a
book and the television series others
had been doing this for some time you
had called Sagan doing cosmos Kenneth
Clarke on Civilization burn-off ski abba
eban on the history of the Jews and so
forth and I think it's a very good idea
I think it's doesn't always work but
when it does it's have a lot of impact
you may tell me this is none of my
business but how does someone over a
seven-year period live day to day did
they pay you during this period I mean
you hear people working on books for all
these years you wonder how they probably
make it well you want to get a handsome
advance if you can although it's not a
way to make money I mean working on
these things you know you could be of
teller in a bank and probably make more
money than you make writing even though
a lot of people think I became a
multimillionaire because the book
Vietnam books older remarkably well I
was doing other things on the side I was
doing some other writing and editing and
I'd save some money and I was getting
paid in a modest way by the television
project as well so while I wasn't
getting rich it was alright it was
comfortable and but you know I don't
work for money I mean I like to earn
money I'm not going to
dr. Johnson once said nobody but a
blockhead writes except for money but
there are other satisfactions I think in
writing and if you look at the average
right across the country you'd probably
find that the main income is something
like six thousand dollars a year so
while you read about these glitzy
contracts of people getting
multi-million dollar advances you also
have to bear in mind that there are a
lot of writers who are struggling when
do you feel a sense of satisfaction what
is it well if every step of the way
first you organize you plan what you're
going to do and you know perfectly well
as you start when you've got a grasp of
the subject this is before you've ever
even done the research but you have a
kind of roadmap of where you want to go
and that's very important you may not
follow that outline I think it's very
important to do a good job of outlining
what you want to do even throw it away
and usually you don't follow it exactly
when I was a young reporter in Paris I
interviewed the great abstract painter
Georges Braque who said to me if I knew
what was going to come out on the canvas
I would bother to paint it because
things develop as you go along so that
first sense of satisfaction is is
getting an idea where you're going then
you start researching and researching is
a little bit like panning for gold you
can just lie by that stream you know
looking for those nuggets to come along
and every once in a while something does
come along and that gives you a great
sense of satisfaction interviewing
people is is fun in many ways especially
if you have time to do it and you can
let it spread out a bit and you can help
the person you're interviewing get over
that initial nervousness especially if
you're doing it jointly on camera many
of the interviews I do in the book will
being done on camera or sometimes I
would do a pre-interview to determine
what
I was going to ask them when we taped
them on camera that takes time and then
you begin to hear those those those
things that you're trying to direct the
person to say something but then you
know that you maybe you're getting
something original from this person or
some new anecdote that hasn't been told
before then you plunge into archives and
start digging out all kinds of things
and there again it's you know you're
down there with that with your helmet
light on in that coal mine you know
chipping away or that gold mine I'm
looking for for this material then you
get it all and I'll pardon me if I mix
my metaphor you're a bit like a sculptor
with this enormous piece of granite and
then you got to chip away at that
granite in order to mold that sculpture
and that is a very hard process I don't
know any writer thinks that writing is
fun it's it's hard work and the way I
did it and do it is just as if I'm doing
any other job I get up in the morning
and I have breakfast and read the
newspapers and shave and shower and get
dressed but I go down to my cellar where
I have my study and work and I try to
get to my machine by 8 or 9 o'clock in
the morning and sometimes I'll run out
of steam in the afternoon but sometimes
I'll go until midnight but you have to
treat it as a job you have to be
disciplined you don't sit around waiting
for inspiration if you do you're never
going to get anything done because it's
much more fun taking the dog out for a
walk along the canal then sitting down
there and writing but again getting back
to your point about the thing that keeps
you going I think is that you you have
these these Peaks in which you really do
begin to feel that you're getting the
story told and this chapter looks pretty
good very often it looks good and you
put it aside you look at it two weeks
later it looks terrible and so you go
back and you work on it again or maybe
your editor doesn't like it very much
sir only partly likes it
so what I'm trying to say is that there
are if there are moments of troughs when
you're not feeling like working best
thing to do and that those moments is
just to get up and take a walk when you
get the whole thing finished there is
that great sense of satisfaction of
having completed it and kept it within
some sort of reasonable bounds I write
books for the public on that an academic
and I don't want to throw 24 volumes at
people and I assure you that I had
enough material doing a 24 volume count
of the story but I wanted to keep it
within reason obviously reasonable
bounds then you wait and you're in a
limbo until the reviews start coming out
in this book in our image I must say
that I've been extremely fortunate I've
had much better reviews than I would
dreamed of having in New York Times The
Washington Post the Boston Globe have
all been very kind and then again
because you've put in so much time you
wait to see what you [ __ ] your ear for
the ring of the cash register to see
whether the book is going to be a good
seller a best seller I think that in my
own mind much more interested in the
longevity of the book what the publisher
is called the shelf life of a book then
I am in the immediate impact I mean I
I'm not going to be I'm not going to
dissimulate and say I don't like to sell
books I think every writer does but I
really like hope that the book is around
for a long time the Vietnam book was
published in late 83 it's still on the
shelves it's being used in schools along
with the television series and I must
say they got a great sense of
satisfaction
gratification when some high school
students or college student calls me up
and in effect asked me to do is turn
paper for them you know my wife has me
the file she said here's another call
from Iowa State or the University of
Florida and there's some college
sophomore there who's taking a course in
Vietnam and and wants to ask me some
questions which if he or she were a
little more enterprising they could
probably find the answers to in the book
but maybe they just want to talk on the
phone down some ideas and that's very
good I get a lot of satisfaction out of
that I get a lot of letters veterans
from Vietnamese refugees or immigrants
now living in this country so you get
the sense that you've put something into
the world that's still there that you
know wasn't one of those quickie
sensations that that came and went and
so I find the you know that that doesn't
give me the sense of some sense a sense
of achievement I find the same thing if
I go out lecturing which I do where as
often as I can in universities don't
forget that it's interesting about
Vietnam it that is that you have a whole
generation of Americans who lived
through it either veterans of the war
the eyes or grunts as we call them
you have the Americans of that
generation who lived at home either
students who were protesting against the
war people who are supporting it and
then you have a whole generation of
Americans who weren't even born when we
got involved and there's an intense
interest in Vietnam in universities and
even in the high schools so that all
contributes to this continuing interest
in the subject and I do feel that it
does give me some role to play in
dealing with the subject now again in
this book in our
image the it's really a book about
America not about the Philippines I mean
if the Philippines is the landscape but
the story is about America going abroad
for the first time in its history at the
turn of the century and becoming a
colonial power what we did in our colony
and what was left behind and I think
there's no other book that spans this
period business gentleman Theodore
Roosevelt one of the architects of our
war with Spain and the man who was
responsible in fact for ordering
Commodore George Dewey who was then
commander of a small squadron of
American ships in Asia Teddy Roosevelt
ordered Dewey to Manila and that was the
beginning of our involvement in
Philippines are you driven to write as a
journalist to transfer information or do
you find yourself having a strong point
of view now at this point in your life
and you want the rest of the world to
know your point of view tell you the
truth I I'm not out grinding axes I do
obviously have a point of view I mean I
think only an amoeba doesn't have an
appointed you any human being that the
the idea objectivity doesn't exist and
in a minute we begin to choose anecdotes
in telling our stories we are becoming
subjective what I try to do is to be
fair which is different from being
objective which is to tell the various
sides of the story but overall I believe
that if you marshal your information if
you tell a story and you are putting
some guidance in there you're selecting
certain things they're trying to make
your point
but overall I like a debate to come out
of it I'd like various readers to find
different things in it and they do I've
had this
experience again going back to Vietnam
because it's too early that the results
in this one are it's too early to tell
but on Vietnam I found myself denounced
by the extreme left and the extreme
right and I figured as a result I must
be doing something right because I
consider myself to be a member of the
extreme center and but I want to tell
all the stories I don't want to try to
bombard a reader with my opinions it
becomes boring it becomes polemical and
when you get into history into the past
it's a marvelous fertile field for
storyteller I mean so much of what went
on in the past is is amusing it's
interesting it's lively I'm not a
novelist sometimes I wish I were but you
don't have to be a novelist to tell
interesting stories as this gentleman
that's author MacArthur who was general
at the turn of the century in the
Philippines one of the early American
commanders and the father of the
illustrious Douglas MacArthur who later
became the American who probably served
longer and was most heralded by the
Filipinos what impact did he have on our
relationships with the Philippines well
he was there at this early period after
we had landed in the Philippines in 1898
we defeated the Spanish as I said duly
defeated the Spanish fleet in seven
hours on May 1st 1898 with the loss of
only one man who died of heat
prostration then American troops began
to come out to fight the Spanish and
there was no battle it was a the United
the Spanish surrendered in August of
1898 so there wasn't any real war
against the Spanish in in the
Philippines as there was in Cuba which
is really the main reason we went to
were against Spain in 1898 after
defeating the Spanish in the summer of
1988 there was a lot of doubt about what
was going to happen in the Philippines
we had a conspicuously indecisive
president at the time m'lady McKinley
and he couldn't make up his mind what to
do and eventually however he decided
that he was going to annex the
Philippines to keep the Philippines he
explained the afterword to a group of
Methodist clergyman that he could not
make up his mind but he said he he was
pacing Lafite paced the floor of the
White House night after night and even
get down on his knees and pray to God
for guidance and then this divine
intervention came in answer to his
prayers and he was told to take the
Filipinos and uplift them and
Christianize them as he put it because
they were all Catholics having been
under Spanish rule for 300 years but it
was an example of how little of McKinley
knew about the Philippines which he
admitted by the way that he couldn't
locate on a map so we decided to retain
these islands but there was a Philippine
nationalist movement that had declared
independence so we went to war to
conquer the Philippines the war is
officially called the Philippine
insurrection in our official records in
fact it was a war of conquest I mean to
put it bluntly and some 4,000 Americans
died in that war and perhaps 200,000
Filipinos died as well so it was a
rather bloody war lasted two and a half
years but we did we did conquer this
movement partly it's because the
Filipino nationalist movement was inept
and disorganized and then we began our
rule with
this is a classic picture who had been
now who are you looking at the water
buffalo or the man sitting on it the
question of course is who weighs more
the man on the water buffalo is William
Howard Taft who was the first American
civilian governor of the Philippines
came out there in 1901 and stayed for
four years later went home to become
secretary war at a time when the War
Department was responsible for the
administration of the Philippines and of
course later was elected president and
never forgot those early years in the
Philippines and and these 13 years or so
when he was governor Secretary of War
and president he was quite responsible
very responsible for setting the pattern
of our colonial rule that lasted until
1946 when he was there how many
Filipinos would probably around the
population was probably around 8 million
6 to 8 million they've never really been
a census and it was in those years of
course a large fairly large population
it's interesting that a Filipino
movement a political party called a
federal Easter party which Taft had
hoped to had helped to organize and
finance had as one of its planks
statehood for the Philippines and its
leaders came to Washington in 1904 to
plead for statehood to become a part of
the Union and the Secretary of State at
the time le root rejected the role
largely on racial grounds he's claimed
if we had a racial problem the United
States and he didn't want any quote
colored or colored people in this
country
those were the mores of the time those
were the norms of the time I might say
another factor of course was to bring an
area of 8 million people into the union
would have made it the biggest state in
the Union and it would have been rather
odd to have the southern speak to have
the tail wagging the dog I mean you
would have had walked Filipino
congressman then congressman from any
other state incidentally there to this
day there's a statehood movement which
claims about 5 million members probably
the Philippines today has a population
of about sixty million so imagine how
many Filipino congressmen you'd have up
on Capitol Hill
if the Philippines ever became a state
this picture that is President Franklin
D Roosevelt signing into law in 1935 the
legislation that created a turn the
Philippines into a Commonwealth and also
more importantly scheduled independence
for ten years later of course
independence was delayed for a year
because of the Second World War
another photograph here of another
president and a couple of other figures
that the audience may recognize who's
the gentleman with the top hat out front
the man with the straw hat er Adam is
Douglas MacArthur then the military
adviser to the Philippine Commonwealth
government he had been chief of staff in
Washington he retired and then was
offered this job to go out there and to
help form a Filipino army now the man
behind him also in the white suit is
directly to his right is that's what a
baby-faced gentlemen there is Dwight the
Eisenhower who was then a major and was
I was MacArthur's deputy chief of staff
during that period of the 1930s they
hated each other they had terrible
fights
Eisenhower was later asked did you ever
know what general McArthur he said yes I
studied dramatics unto him for seven
years
years later when Eisenhower was
president somebody asked MacArthur if he
knew Eisenhower he had known Eisenhower
to which MacArthur replied best clerk I
ever had
there was something incompatible about
their characters MacArthur was a
monumental egotist a talented man a
skilled man in many ways Eisenhower was
essentially a rather modest man and they
disagreed over policy MacArthur was
absolutely convinced that his plan for
defending the Philippines would work and
Eisenhower had strong doubts about it in
the end they broke up and they disliked
each other intensely in fact did General
MacArthur have on what we know today is
a Philippine the big thing that
MacArthur did and what it really has
made him almost a deity to the Filipinos
is that when soon after the outbreak of
World War two when Japanese Japanese
occupied the Philippines and MacArthur
was forced to leave the country
he left his little word out on the
island of corridor and fled to Australia
and he vowed to return those those
famous words of his I shall return
incidentally it wasn't we shall return
it was I shall return again a reflection
of this ego and he did he did in 1944 as
he fought his way up through the Pacific
he approached the Philippines and there
was a big debate in in Washington among
the strategists of where he should go
next on his way or on the as the
American forces approached Japan
and many strategists in the Navy and
Army wanted to go wanted to attack the
island of Taiwan a Cawthra insisted that
we had a commitment to liberate the
Philippines and he finally won that
debate and he did liberate the
Philippines and I went back to the
Philippines with MacArthur on his final
journey there 1961 what he called his
sentimental journey millions of people
came out and he could have got elected
king that he decided to run there was
tremendous emotion and to this day there
still lives toward McCarthy how much
time you've just been around just those
those few weeks on his return I I served
in Asia during the Second World War
fortunately not in his command a lot of
American soldiers a lot of GIS had
tremendous reverence for him I was over
in the China Burma India theater and
that was not the Pacific there he was
the man with faults as well I'd
mentioned the ego his tremendous ego
which tended to blur the achievements of
other generals in that theater you
remember compare them to Eisenhower
Eisenhower was the supreme commander in
Europe we met we remember the names of
the famous generals like Omar Bradley
or-or-or Maxwell Taylor Matthew Ridgway
or George Patton because Eisenhower
allowed the gave them publicity we only
remember one man in the Pacific although
they were other where other very
competent general is like Eagleburger
I go Eichelberger and sorry but he
blotted all those people out what was he
like to sit and just talk to in my own
from my own brief experience with him
MacArthur tended to deliver speeches and
maybe this was because he was light in
his life he talked himself out he said
everything he was ever going to say in
his life I was a reporter he wasn't
about to let what little hair he had
left down in front of me and so I found
those few occasions to be rather stilted
not terribly comfortable this picture
top one that's Ferdinand Marcos and
Imelda Marcos Marcos was the president
of the Philippines with Lyndon Johnson
on a visit to Washington in 1966 and
Lyndon Johnson wanted above all to
persuade Marcos send Filipino troops to
Vietnam and Marcos was very very clever
he extracted a lot of money from Lyndon
Johnson for ten battalions of American
of Filipino troops but in fact I only
sent one over and used the rest of them
to build roads for political purposes
back home this photo there we have
Ronald Reagan then of the want to be on
I'm sorry that's Richard Nixon with the
Marcoses and to the right is Pat Nixon
they didn't get along very well
Nixon whatever you may think of them was
sensitive to the Marcoses efforts to to
manipulate him and at the bottom we have
Ronald Reagan then Governor of
California visiting Manila in 1969
dancing with the beautiful Imelda Marcos
while Nancy Reagan on the other side of
the room of dances with Marcos those
that experienced that first trip that
Ronald Reagan took the Manila really
scratched his mind and from then on he
kept referring to the Marcoses as his
very good friends and in the end was
very very reluctant to see them
overthrown
how would you describe the Filipino as a
person there are very few people
people's if I might put it that way in
the world that I've encountered who was
hospitable and genuinely warm as the
Filipinos are especially toward an
American and I looking at it from a
point of view of a reporter there is
almost total access in the Philippines
if you've over there as a journalist I
mean you could almost have not
exaggerating to say that you can arrive
on a Thursday evening and be having
breakfast with the president of the
country the next morning the breakfast
may stretch into lunch and they stretch
into dinner and it may stretch into a
weekend in the country with them
Filipinos are very talkative of course I
understand as a reporter that they want
something I mean that they're trying to
sell themselves or sell whatever policy
they had nevertheless there is a kind of
Congeniality in Filipinos and I it's not
only the president it's right down to
the lowliest peasant I want to add an
interesting thing is that in the course
of researching of this book on the
television series that we produced we
had to go out with the Filipino
communists into their areas and they're
just as friendly and congenial as you
might find in the government so there is
that extreme warmth and you get a sense
from Filipinos even those who are
rhetorically anti-american rhetorically
critical of the United States that there
is a profound feeling of a pro-american
sentiment there that even that
transcends all that sort of nationalist
rhetoric that you hear mainly in Manila
and this is I think the file photo in
your book that is President Corazon
Aquino kori as we call her
delivering the speech to the joint
sessions of Congress in September 1986
about six or eight months after she was
catapulted into office and that was a
really memorable moment her visit to
Washington really was a crowning one of
her crowning achievements interestingly
enough when she went down that aisle of
of the house and the congressmen were
all wearing yellow ties and yellow cover
buns and yellow flowers because her
color has was yellow all of that kind of
sentimentality of Philippine American
relations bubbled up and suddenly there
was this great great rediscovery by
Americans of this connection that gone
back to the turn of the century well you
really think it's impossible as with all
Filipinos thinking American what is what
are the people who run the country like
this Aquino think of us she said and
she's got a woman to dissimulate she
said in her speech before Congress that
the three years that she was in exile in
Boston from 1980 to 1983 with the three
happiest years of her life she got to
school in New York as a young woman
there is there are very strong ties now
there are two countries and two
countries obviously have their
differences but deep down I think my
experiences that Filipinos do have a
very strong pro-american sentiment some
of the most harshest critics of the
United States when you do a little
scratching you discover their children
live in the United States they have
American residence permits that permit
them to come in and out of the United
States they own houses in the ID stage
when you get down into the villages
it's very rare that you don't find
somebody who's got a cousin in San Diego
or an uncle in Cleveland there are a
million and a half Filipinos living in
the United States and they will soon be
the largest Asian minority so these ties
are not going to disappear overnight the
issue stake right now are the two
American bases in the Philippines the
naval base in the airfield the Filipinos
want more money for them perhaps they
deserve more money for them there have
been recent negotiations which produced
an interim agreement there going to be
new and fresh negotiations I think a
compromise of some sort will be reached
you think what do you think based on
what you've seen in history what will
our relations be say 10 to 20 years from
now well I would like let me let me put
it in terms of what I'd like to see
rather than looking into my clouded
crystal ball and predicting what in fact
will happen in terms of our relationship
I think the biggest challenge to the
Filipinos is to develop a sense of their
own national identity here is a country
and here's where history teaches us
something here is a country whose whole
history has been colonial history in
fact there's no country in the world
that has been a colony longer than the
Philippines the Spanish arrived there in
the 16th century and they finally got
their independence in 1946 before the
Spanish arrived there wasn't any sense
of nationhood the Filipinos have to
develop this sense of nationhood and
that's going to be a major challenge for
them and only when they can do that can
they begin to become truly independent
from the United States because their
independence the independence they got
in 1946 was a kind of dependent
independence they depended on us for aid
they depend on us for advice they depend
us on numerous occasions to help them
put pull the chestnuts out of the fire
they're depending on us right now for
help
fighting the insurgency so they have to
make it on their own and that's going to
be the major challenge for them and I
think it will color their relationship
with us they have to be able to stand up
as a truly sovereign nation this is what
the cover of the book looks like Stanley
Carnot is our guest title is in our
image America's Empire and the
Philippines how much are they living in
our image the image is there when we
went out there we try to turn the
Filipinos into facsimile Americans and
we did to a certain extent
Filipinos copied our music they copied
our dress we taught English and English
is still the common language of the
country they young Filipinos dream of
going to American universities that
gives them a big cachet when they come
home but deep down they still have their
own values and their values are
different from ours we have a society
that we like to think is based on civic
virtue on impersonal institutions
Philippine society is based on personal
relationships based on family ties and
ritual kinship ties and they march to a
different drum be from us I'm not going
to judge whether this is better or not
so when you look back on this hundred
years almost a hundred years of this
American Philippine relationship the
Americanization of the Philippines
Americanized the Filipinos but didn't
make them Americans you born in New York
City right 1925 right studied got a
degree from Harvard that's right they
did also the Sorbonne in Paris but a lot
of your writings in the last several
years had been out in the Far East where
did you get your interest well I started
out as a reporter in Paris in 1950
and worked there as a correspondent for
Time magazine had some interludes back
at Harvard as an Emer fellow
5758 and finally in 58 I had been
spending a lot of time when I was based
in Paris covering events in North Africa
there was a war going on the Algerian
war an effort by the Algerian
nationalists to gain their independence
from France so I actually opened my own
Bureau in North Africa and as so often
happens with big organizations I'd
hardly got settled down there then there
was an opening in Hong Kong and they
said would you like to go and of course
I jumped at it so example of how one's
life can get steered by just some
fortuitous change I mean some Bureau
might have been open in South Africa or
Latin America perhaps I would have gone
there but Asia always interested me not
that I had any special knowledge as I
said I had been out there during the
Second World War but I was just a GI and
really didn't learn a lot I did though
as a GI in in that area in South Asia
I just found it absolutely fascinating I
found it exotic and I felt that even
then that I was only scratching the
surface of it and I really welcome the
chance to go back and learn more about
it and I can tell you one thing about
Asia the more you know the less you know
because it's a as they say it's a it's a
lifetime University that never Awards a
degree because you never get to the
stage where you can claim any expertise
I think I think people claim to be Asia
experts are using a long word I think
you could say you're an Asian specialist
but it's a very complicated area and I
think we can learn a lot about it
and we have learned a lot about it but
it is subtle complex and different and
terribly different in this book about
the Philippines how many years did it
take you to write it it took me about
four years to do the book on the
Philippines and the television series
but I'd like to say that I won't started
going out there in the late 50s when I
stood when I was assigned to Asia so
it's got something like thirty years of
research in it even though at the
beginning I I didn't have any idea of
writing a book but I was always
gathering string and gathering notes and
my advice to every reporter is keep your
notes you never know what you're going
to do with them someday how much actual
shooting did you have to do there either
video tape of film shooting for your
series on PBS we we did hundreds
literally hundreds of interviews with
everybody from Ferdinand Marcos and
Imelda Marcos to President Aquino
various members of her cabinet communist
insurgents and of course the other side
the American side Secretary of State
George Shultz Admiral crowd the chairman
of Joint Chiefs of Staff former
ambassadors CIA men Americans we've
grown up in the Philippines and
reminisced on what life was like in the
20s and 30s and so we have a vast vast
archive of material plus that's film
archive were taped archive plus notes
books and audio tapes as pre interviews
we did documents of all kinds this
country given that philippine experience
this country is a treasure trove of
material whether it's the National
Archives in Washington Library of
Congress different University Archives
army war colleges like the one in
Carlisle Pennsylvania
there's where our history reposes and
it's there and anybody wants to be a
historian just needs a pass to go into
these buildings which are open to the
public did you do all the interviews
yourself
I did most of the interviews on camera
again having spent all those years out
there
I knew all these people so it was easy
enough for me to call them and and get
to see them I had the access I think
however that given their hospitality the
access would have been there for anybody
what are you gonna do with those hours
and hours of interviews never got into
the three hours it was a three hours of
documentary on PBS yeah
well as usual again like writing a book
it's the chipping away at that big block
of granite in order to put to produce
that sculpture I would hope that we
could find a university or foundation
that would be interested in taking these
things because they are I think quite
invaluable in your life you work for The
Saturday Evening Post NBC News
Washington Post you associate editor the
New Republic which of those did you
enjoy the most well I've got this
attitude of a reporter which is the
story I'm working on that day is the
greatest story I've ever done in my life
and wherever I worked I liked it it's
hard to there they were different kinds
of media and I just myself to each one I
tried to some gave me more satisfaction
than others being able to write long
pieces for the late and lamented old
Saturday Evening Post was particularly
satisfactory but on the other hand
working for daily newspaper was
marvelous being out in Asia being on
your own having receptive editors and
without getting a power complex because
I don't think I think that's the
affliction of many journalists but it
was very nice to be able to write a
story and know that the president the
United States was reading it the next
morning along with my wife's aunt Katie
who was also one of my readers so I find
I must say that that I can't think of a
better profession to be than a foreign
correspondent as I've often said it's
the only profession in which you remain
an adolescent all your life because
it's fun it's romantic you're on your
own you have responsibilities but you
have freedom as well
and I regret as my own children are not
terribly interested in in that
profession but or they do my oldest
son's a lawyer my his wife my
daughter-in-law is an anthropologist my
daughter as a professional photographer
and quite successful and my youngest son
is just about to graduate from Harvard I
only have a couple minutes left from
what you've learned as a reporter and a
journalist and a writer and television
producer over the years somebody made
you secretary of state all of a sudden
what are some of the principles you
would use in our foreign policy with the
areas you've covered so much over there
in Southeast Asia Matt well let me
preface it by saying it I would I would
reject the offer if I was over the job I
think that the main thing we have to
understand about dealing with other
countries is that they've got their
internal dynamics just as we have every
time we face a foreign policy issue and
you studied careful study it carefully
you discover that domestic politics is
probably the largest quotient in the
formulation of foreign policy other
countries have the same thing we beef
about the Japanese and their trade
problems they've got a legislature
they've got political parties they've
got pressure groups in vested interests
and the same is true whether you're
going to talk about Asia or Europe I
think our biggest problem because we're
so new to the world is that it's hard to
put ourselves inside the skins of the
people of other countries and I think
that's where you have to start and when
you don't do that when you don't try to
see things from their point of view then
you get into trouble mind you it's very
important that you have to realize that
you are representing the United States
that that's your your main client is the
American public is the American are the
American people but you're only going to
get along with other countries
and progress in getting your problems
dealt with if you try to understand it
from their point of view and that's a
rare it's we aren't we're so young that
you know we've only spent a few years
out in the world it's only essentially
since the end of the Second World War
that we've been really exercising
Authority and influence in the world
next project for Stanley Karnow I would
like to look in to the possibility of a
book in another television series on
this vast influx of Asians into the
United States remind you I am NOT
calling it the Yellow Peril as some
people are just the contrary the
interesting thing about the Asians the
Chinese the Japanese the Koreans the
Vietnamese Cambodians Indians Pakistanis
coming to United States if they're
coming in with all the old American
virtues family hard work risks and
endurance stamina and I think they're
making a positive contribution to this
country here's the book in our image
America's Empire in the Philippines
Stanley Carnot is the author and he's
been our guest for the last 60 minutes
thank you very much thank you